[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
[Music]
my dearest Dominic here we are on the
Friendship onion we're back again I love
it we're wearing two different trousers
well we always do sometimes we wear
jeans at the same time oh I I thought
you remember we wore the same trousers
oh no one I'm in the left leg you're on
the right but I like that color trousers
I was saying that earlier on I'm a
little colorblind how do you describe
the color of that trouser olive green
fantastic what would you call them
desert cocky desert Safari Safari
deserts Santan Santan okay great well we
got through the uh the trouser section
um how's it going you've been to Hawaii
Aloha Mahalo
um yeah I was working over there just
for a a short time and I hadn't been
near Hawaii for a while and uh I liked
it it's a great part of the world well
you spent a long time there doing lost
didn't you love the humidity
I love it yeah it's nice it's almost as
hot as L.A sometimes hotter than L.A
yeah it was hotter it was hotter but way
more humid and I like that humidity I
know what you mean don't you don't get
that ah painful uh it's more like oh I'm
not younger yeah you're in a jungle in a
greenhouse it feels good for your skin
good for you around
just general over overall health there's
a great phrase I mean it's a word but
it's actually two words together so it
kind of kind of a phrase it is that they
use in Hawaii I don't know if you've
heard it I remember here we are called
the kind you know that's Dakine well
there's a there's a shoe surf yeah what
does it mean the kind so it's D A and
then the separate word k-i-n-e yeah yeah
Dakine
is I've put some stuff on my mic there
is for um
is for anything that you can't think of
the name of it should be like oh but
pass me the kind oh how was surfing
today oh it was the kind oh way up to
after this I'm going to uh the kind I
just know that it's a filler now I think
that also exists in other languages but
we don't have it in English do we we'd
say finger me or whatever but decline is
actually decaying I'm going to use that
great well I'm always searching for
words so that's a good one it's a very
good unless I start searching for the
kind
peeling The Onion
well we've had some correspondence so we
Jump Right In because we've got our
stack show today we've got a fantastic
guest tons of housekeepings to do Tom
quite a few people tried making my uh
potato pancakes oh or potato scones
Tony Caro did he says how did you make
potato pancakes sound so wonderful well
we have been eating those my whole life
he says I usually have patties it's the
same concept but instead of rolling the
dough out yeah and cutting it into
triangles which is very important in my
style as you know John yeah we just make
the parties like you would a hamburger
Brown on top and a bottom and it's
fluffy in the inside to add flavor
mince chives or like a chive we add that
to the door also really good with sour
cream like latkes
potato like it you like that yeah which
is they use shredded potato of course
instead of mashed but uh people around
the world love potato pancakes of some
tape that's true you find them
everywhere really yeah but those flat
potato scones ah well you've you and I
have not done a billion Dominique the
world personally have we like we've not
done our own so possibly at one point
you could make your potato pancakes and
bring them in and then
you've never tasted them have you I've
never had them on the morning of your
wedding oh yeah but were they might yeah
I mean you buried it
um
what's the fastest cake in the world
it's gone well done oh lovely stuff
um
Jane Harding wrote was on YouTube uh
regarding the hand tattoo that Billy
suggested putting on his chest Jane said
after Billy mentioned uh tattooing his
hand on his chest and making it into the
United and making it into the shape of
the United States I'm thinking we need
this printed on t-shirts or some sort of
friendship onion merch that's a great
idea that's a good idea the Friendship
onion map of America yeah based on your
wonderful hand and you do have wonderful
hands yeah I've got two of them oh yeah
you do yeah and uh they look quite
similar and would we actually have
the the states I think you should all of
them oh shoot that's a good way to learn
isn't it guess what maybe we separate
the states into where the borders are
but not put the name on it and then you
have to go a point and go that's there
or what if the the states were written
in like that invisible link that you
have to shine a UV torch on
and the T-shirt comes with a UV torch
the t-shirts glow in the dark as well as
glow in the UV you're right like a uh
like a scorpion yeah
um we've got another one here about
maple syrup shall I read this one
because this was a little bit about what
I said
um
Marin is that how you would say this
lady's name I would say mirin yep
I hope I've got your name right you got
a perfect job who told us I have to put
my two cents in here as a woman who
thought maple syrup would be awesome in
the context that Don mentioned I
remember you mentioned in that on a
woman
uh because she loves maple syrup she
says I can say it was incredibly an
annoyingly sticky in a cumbersome and
distracting sort of way best reserved
for the gastronomic Arts instead just a
friendly warning now someone has poured
maple syrup on it well you see I thought
that wouldn't be pleasurable
I think in the moment in that first
minute yeah it's pleasurable because you
think lovely woman lovely skin lovely
taste sweetness but then as the time
goes on you might get a Fluff on it even
if I'm eating pancakes I'd get someone
my thumb that annoys me
as a kid you know when you your parents
would give you an ice cream cone but you
weren't old enough to be able to
negotiate with the with the melting and
it would go down your hand I used to
have a really hard time with that
it's become a claw what did your mum do
I think she would just take my um ice
cream off me and eat it
yeah don't do it quite a tragic deal
though it was actually my mom got in
touch with me today as she is once I am
Maureen I am Maureen hiya Momo and said
that um
when we were kids we lived in Germany we
would come back to Manchester and upon
leaving Manchester my dad's late mother
my grandma would very often give us like
a joint of meat you know like a giant
beef or a joint of hand Silverside or
something yeah something like that to go
back with yeah and uh in a way that we
got a song lyric uh wrong on purpose my
brother and I would sing based on that
uh beautiful Paul Young song every time
you go away
you take a piece of me meet with you
lovely stuff so send us in any of your
um lyrics that you purposefully get
wrong oh someone else said Remember the
um Madonna erotica stuff yeah yeah
you're ready yeah
uh one of our friends said that when
they were kids they used to sing
billardi
a lot of goody
I like the goodies too and he's now
become almost a professional bird
watching right he is a professional Bud
Watcher he gets paid for watching buds
so that yeah you know the slang of what
a bird watcher is no a twitcher a
Twitter because they're constantly like
that oh yeah watching buds now you were
going to tell me about a song lyric I
think no before that I was going to tell
you about talking about uh slabs and
mate please my mother we didn't often
have a lot of money in our house when I
was growing up right and one time we got
a lovely big silver side now watch
Silverside it's like a it's a good cut
of like beef it's like a big you know
what I mean we were right it would do
the house all week it would do our
Sunday roast but then we'd have it the
rest of the weekend sandwiches what a
treat my mother cooked it stuck it on
the kitchen table there was a boxer dog
next door to us called Tara
took the whole bloody things on I bet
sorry I got a beating didn't you trying
to get chased right down the street with
my mum she never caught her
we've got a friend who will remain
nameless who who used to like throwing
his dog up in the air when it misbehaved
remember that well I never late that
don't I didn't like seeing it either I
love I love dogs right I love dogs too
couldn't eat a whole one so you were
asking about
um lyrics uh mishaired lyrics yes or
purposely Miss sang lyrics There here's
a Dave Willett says what's up Dave
Eleanor rugby by The Beatles I always
sing I look at all the lovely people
all the lovely people well that's lovely
he says he's wave correct some every
time but he says I can't sing it any
other way well I also think instead of
lonely singing lovely is just a
wonderful way maybe in your life maybe
Mr McCartney could uh have a look at
that and maybe change those he's only
man that's allowed to change those
lyrics you know true at this point yeah
you're getting a job
well no that was the only one that I
remember
um put your hands all over my body and
uh every time you go away you take a
piece of meat with you hey here's the
thing somebody tells us something from
nothing this person's called and
remember when we're eating apples of
course I do you have a lovely one crazy
and remember the seeds and I said you
shouldn't eat this it's a small amount
of cyanide isn't it is it cyanide done
but something from nothing says it would
take around
200 apples
to be enough to kill you I mean if
anyone can eat 200 apples it might be me
right so don't eat the seeds then I
genuinely I said this to you last the
the time when we did the episode of the
apples it's one of the nicest
compliments that you've ever said to me
that you consider me to be the person
who eats the most amount of apples
you've ever met in your life that's a
wonderful complex I love an apple of me
yeah you do but why maybe someone out
there can tell us why hi would an apple
seed contain cyanide what is the benefit
for the Apple because an apple wants its
seeds to be eaten and then transported
to different parts of the area so that
it can have more sort of trees through
the small intestine you mean yes the
possibly passing through a bird's anus
so do you think maybe actually a bird's
anus do you think cyanide maybe prevents
it being eaten by the the um the stomach
acid
if anyone knows if you could write to us
uh the Friendship onion at castmedia.com
is it now this is only a guess right go
is it to stop a large animal from eating
lots and lots of apples and then just
literally dumping them all in one spot
as opposed to a small animal eating one
apple and moving away because they think
well if ate too many I get gutsy ache so
if you what you're saying is if there
was a bunch of rhinocerai right and one
of them went to eat like 200 apples his
mom
yeah would say Don't eat 200 of them
198. you're all right cut yourself off
because I cyanate that very tiny bit and
then he'll he'll take that and pass it
down in a darwinian way Jerry Seinfeld
has a great bit about uh rhinoceros and
also uh nose jobs because you know the
the Latin term for a nose job is
rhinoplasty yeah which is a shame if
you're going in for a nose job and
someone's referring to you as a rhino
well it's from the Latin you see them
well yeah no big nose right you don't
want to you know
point out like that do you it's a bit
it's a bit uncouth
fair enough one of the few things that
you can only be on of you can't be couth
can you
you can only be oh you can only be on
because you can be cursed one cannot be
cured no
um I don't think we've had any more
tongue twisters or have we have you had
a tongue twister via a voicemail there's
a few tongue twisters loving the we're
loving the tongue twisters Johnny's been
practicing them all week he's amazing
I've shaved off two seconds from the
Peter Piper and you you'd be working on
that we I remember telling you this back
in New Zealand because this is one of
the this is one of the few things that I
can do really well I can do a relatively
complicated
um tongue twister very well I'll do it
for you right now you'll know Eddie
I'm not a pheasant plucker I'm efficient
block of sun and I'm only plug
confessions to the Pheasant blocker
comes that was amazing that's not easy
we should get Johnny Clays to try it
himself but do you want to try that I'll
slow it down first and you I'm not a
pheasant blocker I'm a pheasant
plucker's son right and I'm only
plucking pheasants till the pheasant
plucker comes that's all it is is simply
that a pheasant plucker yeah I'm not a
pheasant plucker I'm a pheasant plucker
son I'm only plucking pheasants till the
pheasant plucker comes that was great
and that was a few seconds that was like
was that all right four seconds I'll
keep working on that okay good
um I'm not a pheasant blocker I'm a
pheasant plucker son I'm only plucking
pheasants till the pheasant plucker
comes brilliant thanks Don yeah it's not
an easy one because if you trip up you
do accidental uh Square buds maybe maybe
we could do more later but um I know we
have a fantastic game we do have an
amazing guess who we should bring on
Matt just to just to conclude on the um
tongue twisters which I thought was
hilarious when we did it my favorite
thing about you with the tongue twisters
is when you were doing Peter Piper you
suddenly morphed into a member of the
English royal family so you're like
right okay let's go
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled
peppers
from us from the RP class and so in
Drama College I think it's to like get
your mouth around the words a little
better you just become more a little
more English
right how do you like your coffee
full-bodied something a little later
we've all got our preferences and no
matter what you like to drink Trade
coffee makes it easy to brew your best
cup at home now these Trade coffee
people are fantastic I started using
them a couple of weeks ago and the every
coffee they've sent has been amazing
they deal only in the freshest roasted
and ethically Source bins from America's
best independent Roasters they ship free
to you as often as you like and you can
have whole beans or ground anything I
like whole beans I like the noise in the
machine
anyway whether you're a coffee nerd or
you just want a better cup these are the
guys to go to take the coffee quiz on
their website to get started Trade
coffee guarantees you'll love the first
bag or they'll replace it for free trade
has been featured in New York Times wire
GQ and delivered over 5 million bags of
coffee honestly it's fantastic and
there's no hassle you can skip shipments
you can change how frequent you get it
you can cancel at any time and for our
listeners right now Trade coffee is
offering a total of 20 dollars off your
first three bags when you go to drink
tree read.com slash onion that's more
than 40 cups of coffee for free to get
started take their Quizlet
drinktrade.com onion and start your
journey to your perfect cup that's
drinktree.com onion for twenty dollars
off your first three bags
it's hard to imagine that spring is
almost here we are so close to that
lovely feeling of nice soft grass
beneath your feet but first off you need
to sort out your lawn now who's going to
help you do that Sunday and it's easy
you just go to their website
getssundee.com and if you're worried
about chemicals you don't need to worry
Sunday's gotta organized I've got a
little dog and I don't want my little
dog all running around pesticides and
all that rubbish on my lawn you don't
need to worry about that with Sunday
traditional Lawn Care lays down 90
million pounds of pesticides each year
Sunday is different they're on a mission
to change how people care for their
yards Sunday can help you grow a
beautiful lawn without the guesswork or
the nasty chemicals you just go to their
website
getsunday.com put in your address your
name and then they work it out from
there they'll send you the best stuff
for your lawn and it's easy to use I was
using it last week and it's made a
difference already
and Sunday is offering our listeners 20
Off full season plans start at just 129
and you can get 20 off at checkout when
you visit getsunday.com onion 20. that's
20 off your custom plan at getsunday.com
onion 20.
Johnny do you want to try uh our tongue
twister because Billy got it perfect you
want me to do as fast as possible please
well we continue Johnny you ready all
right I mean I'm alone
I'm going to give you a three two one
okay right you ready so you go on go
okay all right yeah three two one go I'm
not a pheasant [ __ ] I'm a pheasant
[ __ ] son I'm only plucking potatoes
here we go three girls John three two
one go I'm not the peasant Gators oh
dear no we can't have that potatoes
taters haters John I'll I'll just give
you a demo here we go watch this I'll
give you a time and dump three two one
go I'm not a pheasant Blocker on my
first block of sun and I'm only plucking
pheasant so the pheasant plucker comes
three seconds and 28 that's less than a
second that's like seeing the Beatles
report right John it's your last goes
all right
just get it to the engine just get it to
the end the time doesn't matter what was
it you said to uh Dom last week just
take it easy you ready three two one go
I'm not the pheasant plucker I'm the
Pheasant fucker's son I'm only plucking
thousands until the Pheasant Pluckers
come and that was terrible
I mean the stuff he knows about these
Lord of the Rings things you won't
believe all right go on Tony
good morning boys hello hello
or friendly neighborhood episode artist
it's Tuesday morning I've just listened
to the new episode and I'm about to
start my drawing but I wanted to drop a
line to say while I considered holding a
tongue twister contest among my family
it just wouldn't matter because I would
smoke them all I happened to be pretty
good at tongue twisters and to prove it
I present to you live on voicemail Peter
Piper okay here we go
Peter Piper picked a pick of pickled
peppers to pick up pickled peppers Peter
Piper picked a Peter Piper picked a peck
of pickled peppers where's the peck of
pickled peppers Peter Piper picked
so yeah
dumb I don't sing was that the fastest
Peter Piper you've ever heard it was for
me yeah I mean and it was perfect wasn't
it it wasn't even as if it was no it
wasn't it wasn't like
um that was fantastic it was amazing
lovely what send us in your successful
or unsuccessful attempts at tongue
twisters we like the unsuccessful ones
too and send us in really tricky ones
for Billy and I do Irish Irish wrist
watch Irish wrist watch
Irish wristwatch do it Irish wrist watch
Irish wrist watch Irish wrist watch it's
tough right that's so hot you gotta pull
that face right well let's intro our
guests are you doing the intro I'm gonna
do the intro right come on then Tom
because the Lord of the Rings trilogy
was such a momentous task for anyone to
try and attempt to do Mr Peter Jackson
of course
um
he utilized the help of some very
talented uh producers and humans yeah
and our guest Mr Mark or desky he's
coming in a second
um was an incredible help not only to
Pete but also to us the actors and was
one of the major kind of go-betweens
from the studio over in the United
States to
New Zealand I'll read a little blurb
here about Marco before you do please I
was just thinking about it last night
and I was thinking all the moving pieces
that had to fit together
to just get Lord of the Rings made I
think people forget because it was a
success like how difficult all that must
have been and all those moving pieces I
would say
Mark is one of the most important pieces
yeah that and we're going to find out
that why right in the middle of all of
it he's almost like a crossroads right
and and he was also wearing so many
different hats for different people
because for us as actors he was kind of
our friendly approachable producer that
we can also hang out with and ask
questions of but then he's doing stuff
with Pete and he's doing stuff with the
studio and he's doing stuff with the
crew and he was in New Zealand a lot
wasn't it yeah and through his work with
the new line at that time he was already
a fan of Peace before Lord of the Rings
in it it'll be good to ask him about
that stuff we're going to ask you I'll
read a little bit of facts
markodeski who we know who we call Marco
is an American film and television
producer probably best known for
executive producing the Oscar win in
Lord of the Rings trilogy during which
he spent the best part about five years
in New Zealand supporting his friend
Peter Jackson's historic Vision whilst
growing up and in Indie Studio new line
cinema mark acquired or exec produced
over 60 films 6-0 collectively grossing
nearly 4 billion dollars at the
worldwide box office earning 38 Academy
Award nominations and 18 wins
my goodness including the company's
first best picture nominee and its first
Palm Door the canned Film Festival Mark
also helped introduce Jackie Chan to the
U.S audience with the breakout hit
Rumble in the Brooks Bronx Mark
currently runs independent production
company Court five with fellow new line
veteran Jen Fleming fashioning
independent film and TV content for
Hollywood Studios and broadcasters as
well as Global streamers wow what a CV
regular
curriculum bad time so let's welcome on
to the Friendship onion Mr Mark
odeski
foreign
Billy Mark's here hello Mark hey hey
how's it going oh my gosh it's so good
to see you guys we were just saying off
uh off Mike there when was the last time
you and I saw each other we went for
lunch because we were talking about
Dungeons and Dragons yeah you were
getting ready to play yeah I ended up uh
playing with a company called helpful
goat that was really fun when did you
guys last see each other
we I think it was a screening of some
yes so it may have been one of The
Hobbit movies maybe I better what the
back is that it could have been the last
Hobbit movie time goes it really does it
does it does well Ma I think a lot of
people out there are going to be really
fascinated to
try and understand
what it took for you to get to the lofty
position to be able to be one of the
producers of Lord of the Rings sure so I
wonder if maybe we could go all the way
back and you could maybe tell us as a as
a young adult how you wanted to get
involved in TV and film and what you
needed to study because what an
incredible amount of achievements you've
you've done in your career and I'm sure
people would think well maybe I'll try
and do what Marco odeski did yeah I was
I was very fortunate
um
it starts out as relates to Lord of the
Rings it goes back to 12 or 13 years old
when I read the books and that got me
into Dungeons and Dragons which takes us
right to now as well but in terms of the
film and the film business I was in
university I was studying print
journalism and I wrote a short story for
a class which through a series of
circumstances that could really only
happen here in Los Angeles that story
got put into development at one of the
major Studios
through no real effort of my own
um it just kind of happened and it was a
moment of great Good Fortune timing and
privilege that it did happen that way
but anyway what's more importantly after
that
I got a job reading screenplays for
producers and Executives to help them
deal with the volume of material they
got and when I had that job I sort of
realized that I was never going to be as
good a writer as the writers that I was
reading but I had a knack for
identifying talented writers and almost
more importantly for advocating
on their behalf so when I read something
I really dug I had the ability to be
persuasive about it to the people I was
working for and I realized in that
moment that was that was going to be my
main skill that's like the gift that you
that you found now when when you said
you were reading other writes scripts
and stuff we were you still studying at
University or that was your actual job
at that that was my actual job I when I
wrote this short story I went off the
journalism path and I got on this
Hollywood path right and what happened
to the short story did it ever get made
never got made it was in development at
TriStar for four years and uh then it
just came back to me most of the things
don't get made right we know that don't
we yeah
um okay so then you became advocating
The Talented writers and then did you
start to kind of catch fire with a few
people that actually did turn their
projects no actually it's super helpful
I got fired from that job it's the only
job I've been fired from so far but the
two things I really loved in that job
two films back to the mid 80s now which
was a Mystic Pizza which is Julie
Roberts first film and Major League I
love those scripts
and after I got fired those scripts got
made and they turned into successful
movies and I thought that's it but I did
get a job this company new line Cinema
which was looking for freelance script
readers and I got a job at another
company called Republic pictures that
was looking for script readers so I
would run around hustling
getting paid 30 bucks a script to do
coverage you know analysis of scripts
right and that's what I did so where are
you sorry where were you before new Lane
was it was one of the big studios it was
with a company that had a deal at
TriStar the studio I was I where my
story was
and at that point new line obviously
post-lord the Rings new line are known
as the studio that created the the Lord
of the Rings trilogy pre-loaded the
Rings they were The Nightmare on Elm
Street Studio yeah for sure when I got
there it was after nightmare announce
three part three but I think before
Nightmare on Elm Street part four and
those films the nightmare films are
critical to new line those those were
those were the engine that pulled the
train in those days is before Ninja
Turtles before house party before all
those other franchises that new line got
into and what would you say defined new
lines signature as opposed to the other
Studios out there what when you read a
script and you thought oh this is
perfect for new line what was that it
was usually left of center and it was
usually not dependent on the kind of big
stars that only the major Studios could
afford to pay new line didn't have the
money to to sort of negotiate for big
big stars so we had to sort of make
films that created stars and it's not
it's not coincidental that
um you know Jim Carrey in The Mask or
Austin Powers Mike Myers you know that
we would make films that would create
stars of course yeah indeed
and by the way Lord of the Rings Peter
Jackson that fit the new line Credo
entirely right yeah yeah so what so
you're reading scripts for new Lane when
was the first time that you
got to produce a movie it was Critters
part three and four the irony is my very
first films that I got to work on were a
pair of sequels low budget straight to
video sequels for these new line films
in the in the old library Critters which
were about sort of big furballs from
outer space
sure so Jennifer Aniston in crits is
three yeah she's in one of the critters
I don't think so
yeah but we we made a pair you know the
company wanted these these films
um we've got a warehouse in Santa Monica
and we made Critters go to outer space
which is really just being in a
spaceship and critters go to the big
city which is really just in an
apartment so we had a Sound Stage we had
sort of the apartment set on one side we
had a spaceship set on the other side we
had the same crew different directors
um different editors and different casts
obviously and that was it's pretty funny
that that's how it started so is the
business model that because I'm in the
critters the first one being a bit of a
a success a kind of a bit of a you know
breakout success independent success
from there is the business model with
new line let's try and rush out kind of
maybe a straight to video sequel make
some fast money like were they trying to
turn it into a news no basically new
line had a whole theatrical business
because I was a junior executive they
thought they could make some money
making low budget sequels to sort of
fill in the gaps within the business and
no one really at new line at the time on
the production team really wanted to do
these low budget movies so I sort of got
the job because no one else wanted to do
the job right
um and they said well Mark will do it so
they sort of said yeah go do it here's
your budget you know stay Within These
parameters don't screw it up
um and off you go and how how did that
how did that feel that new job how did
you take to producing at that point it
was exciting I mean we had two main
experienced producers uh Rupert and it
was Barry Opera and Rupert Harvey who
were basically were my mentors because
they were really producing the movie I
was like the executive producer who was
sort of just enabling it would sort of
way it echoed everything I would grow up
to do basically I was there to help get
them whatever they needed right that was
my main function it basically presses
the entire Lord of the Rings thing and
everything I ever did because that was
my function but it was great to be out
from behind the desk and not just
writing analysis right right and gaining
a little bit of momentum so that when
Lord of the Rings comes down the pike
you can be kind of like in the great
position to be one of those yeah and for
anyone that's uh that's watching and
listening that wants to know how to get
ahead at this I mean some of it is luck
and timing I was very fortunate because
I was making these straight to videos
sequels and then Sex Lies and videotape
happened and at the Sundance Film
Festival and suddenly people realized
that you could have a really exciting
sexy business from these upscale Art
House films and they wanted someone who
was kind of aggressive who they thought
might have some taste to go spearhead
our efforts in that area and they sort
of looked at me and said right no more
straight to video sequels for you now
you're going to be the Art House person
so they just aimed me over in that
direction and I was I'm a pretty Earnest
person I was even more Earnest then so
you know so basically once I was given
that job I took a deadly deadly
seriously right and I went to film
festivals and I went racing around and I
was really really lucky because I got to
acquire distribution rights to all these
terrific films and even the ones I
didn't get I got to compete for so at
that point then you're going to all
these film festivals seeing these sort
of art host movies and then you're
trying to bring them to new line to
distribute exactly so is this how you
first saw a Pete Jackson movie or no
Peter Jackson precedes all of this in
the mid 80s I was working for a
different company called Republic
pictures that did straight to video
films and I acquired Finnish movies
b-movies and I got bad taste sent to me
by the New Zealand phone commission and
I desperately wanted to license the
distribution rights of this film and I
failed my bosses thought it was weird
and violent and bloody and it had
accents this is like 1985. they're like
no no no no we're not doing a foreign
film I said what in English it's from
New Zealand but anyway so what did you
see in bad taste that made you think
this is a fantastic film it was just so
kinetic and Innovative and imaginative
but the thing I really did and this is
the most important thing from this whole
anecdote is after I failed I wrote a
letter to Peter Jackson care of the New
Zealand film commission I just stick it
in a mailbox because it was the 80s and
I said listen you don't know me but I
tried to license your film and I failed
I failed you but don't worry he must
have thought I was a freak funny
Someday I'm gonna be something in this
town and then I won't fail you
and he wrote back like cheers thank you
thanks you're weird
you're weird let's be friends but anyway
but I did follow up with him because
then I went over to new line at that
point a new line was accompanied with a
theatrical distribution business
suddenly every problem at new line I had
the solution it was Peter Jackson any
film that didn't have a director I had
the director for them Peter Jackson
people must have thought I was insane
but I talked it up enough and then when
the Nightmare on Elm Street film series
was sort of flagging a bit yeah
um I said why don't we hire Peter
Jackson
to do one we were always hiring multiple
people like you Michael
Freddy goes to the big city and you're
writing Freddy goes to outer space and
Peter Jackson is writing what you know
so we were always doing multiple once
because yours might be part six yours
might be part seven fair enough
and they let me hire him for what it
never got made was it full it would have
been it would have been after the dream
child so that's Dream Shots three right
the dream child I think was five it
would have been instead of New Nightmare
maybe so was it written it was written
it exists how was it it's fantastic oh
man what a shame I'll only tee it up for
you because it's too fun although it
takes so long otherwise but no it's good
it's basically the whole conceit was
Freddy is so played out that no one in
Elm Street is scared of him anymore in
fact kids go to sleep on purpose Like
Clockwork Orange style right just to
beat up on him right right and he's weak
he hasn't had a real victim in years and
then through a series of circumstances
he manages to get one victim he manages
and just enough
to kind of get with it and he realized
he's so angry he decides he's going to
pull all of Elm Street into Nightmare
well there's no forget these one kid and
then another kid forget all that we're
gonna go big or go home we're just gonna
pull the entirety of Elm Street into the
dream world and that was the conceit oh
that's great that's great I mean this
business is full of incredible scripts
written by amazing filmmakers that never
got made yeah for sure I'm sure he has a
bunch of those I know JJ had written a
Superman script that never got off the
ground and there's tons of Batman
scripts that never happens I'm sure
Spider-Man scripts right
um so okay so you're you're championing
Peter Jackson you tried to do this thing
with Nightmare on Elm Street Pete was
obviously down to do it they s how did
that not happen it just when when they
went the other direction as happens yeah
you know Pete went on to do other things
you know he went on at that point he did
Heavenly Creatures he did The
Frighteners right but then of course he
went to do Lord of the Rings and of
course couldn't get it done the way he
wanted to get it done at the company
that was then Miramax yeah and when that
started to happen and they were trying
to sort of you know essentially
make a situation where he had to leave
the project if he was going to insist on
making it his way
he I mean his agents and everyone they
called everyone of course and he called
me and said listen
I've got three weeks
set this up on terms where Miramax won't
make it or I'm not going to be on the
project anymore right so this is our
chance
so it was just a fortuitous moment
there's a lot of Providence involved
because he he says I've got the pitch
you don't have to worry about the pitch
you just need to lay the groundwork and
new line at that point was it a in a
situation where we had been frustrated
by our inability to make sequels to our
Jim Carrey hits the mask and Dumb and
Dumber right and we tried to make the
foundation Trilogy and that hadn't
happened and so I simply put the thought
out there that well we should do this
because we're making the sequels in
advance you don't have to be frustrated
you'll already have them built in yeah
now of course I was talking about one
sequel because Peter and Fran were
pitching two films but then Bob shade
the founder and chairman of new line
actually went up it and said no three
which is obviously the the way that it's
done because the books have split into
three yeah when it was two
Pete it obviously taught you through how
that was looking can you remember where
this where the first film would have
ended
from memory I want to say Helms Deep but
I would the end of Helm Studio at the
beginning I think it might be the end
but I would want to test I wouldn't want
to trust my memory entirely yeah right
so at this point because I know you've
taught you know over the years about the
fact that you know Pete had come over
and slept on your couch at one point
which is a block from New Life he had
been to La a few times had you traveled
to New Zealand at that point I finally
did and I ended up meeting him he came
to the air I was traveling through and
he basically met me at the airport and
we hung out right at the airport it was
sad but then eventually I got to go to
his house and he showed me the little
house from bad taste the miniature you
know that uh that he explained you gotta
remember I knew so little about how
films were actually made right that to
see the little house which on film looks
like a big house and I'm like this is
like magic yeah oh so he he had like a
miniature uh yeah or with a bigger chair
so he did that at that time there was a
real house but he had built a miniature
house which takes off into outer space
and that's how he did that stuff yeah
can I go off topic for a second William
Canna just I know because we're getting
to some really good meaty stuff yeah
yeah you want to do more of the
vegetables no I was just thinking there
when Mark was talking about distribution
and straight to video and all that and
you might not have an answer to this
because this is a question about growing
up uh in in Glasgow Scotland but where I
grew up and videos came out
and there was little video stores or
your local store would have videos
bad taste was always there yeah so along
with Warriors
and critters maybe maybe
the whale Bunch why would those movies
always the video store movies
it's part of it was genre right people
people sort of knew the kind of movies
they got rented a lot and they tended to
be in certain Dependable genres but
there was something about it especially
when I I went and met Pete Jackson and I
thought why was bad taste always even if
a a little video store that had 10
movies that would always be one of them
it scared me that cover as well the
cover that covers the kind of gnarly
looking it almost looks like an orc yeah
with the alien giving the finger giving
the finger I remember it scaring me as a
kid I was like oh that's very aggressive
very aggressive I always thought that
was a crazy sort of thing and then and
then I met him and I thought it was such
a big part of my growing up because it
was one of the few videos that was
always there yeah that you could always
get anyways
if you're digressing I want to digress
as well ma if you you had said that for
a while they're going back a little bit
you would establish yourself as someone
who had great taste in independent
cinema or a kind of champion of
independent filmmakers for people out
there because I think unfortunately now
we are moving in the industry where it's
very difficult for it or much more
difficult for independent filmmakers to
get ahead and sadly for independent
films to be seen
are there any
films in that independent film Canon
that you would recommend people to watch
or as an independent filmmaker right how
do they how do they navigate their way
through this Marvel Disney right world
nowadays you mean in terms of people
making independent films yeah right it
used to be easier is that would that be
accurate to say it's always been hard it
it is harder because the model of making
independent films aside from like the
real DIY kind of independent films right
like Pete's stuff yeah then you you know
you you'd find like a foreign sales
company and a bank and a U.S distributor
and you'd sort of Cobble together the
pieces the financial pieces and build
them together and now because of the
global streamers that kind of model is
less prevalent now right
um and so it's harder but so the global
streamers put out more content but not
always of the sort we're talking about
right but I kind of feel like
it's all about adaptability like if you
want to make films you have to make them
at whatever level you're you're able to
and have faith that that your voice will
be the distinctive thing that cuts
through you know which I know sounds
incredibly like like Pollyanna to say
but but I think that's honestly the only
way to do it right and are there any
independent films that you think are
essential for people to watch and study
and Oh you mean like historically yeah
you know someone's someone's sat home
thinking I'd love to be an independent
filmmaker what should I be watching what
should I study
I think it's it's two ways to look at
one you can look at filmmakers like you
know certain filmmakers you know there's
a certain case studies that transcend
their period of time like you can always
look at someone like in the genre space
other than Pete like there's you know
Robert Rodriguez For example whose first
film was literally like a seven thousand
dollar movie and then how he leveraged
and navigated that you can look at the
classic American Independent you know
kind of filmmakers whether it be you
know John sales or you know from the
American South like it's really about
picking a filmmaker do you have a
favorite film mom I I've I do have a
favorite film it always rotates but my
ultimate favorite film oddly is
Apocalypse Now that's mine too is that
true yeah it's my all-time favorite film
there you go wow I can watch that film
over and over it's like the greatest
biggest independent film of all time
right I'm a sucker big surprise Lord of
the Rings right I'm a sucker for
anything when when Studios do something
bold daring that really pushes the
envelope by backing a filmmaker that
stuff is catnip to me
um and you can find a lot of films but
that one particularly because of the
vision of that and how hard and Barry
Osborne right as you know who produced
um Lord of the Rings with Peter and Fran
um he was a upm on apocalist now did he
ever tell you the story about the
elephant no go on okay so you know
there's you know in the compound with
Colonel Kurtz there's like all kinds of
crazy stuff and there was supposed to be
I guess an elephant the thought with
Francis before couple had this idea oh
there should be an elephant right
and there was only one elephant it was
in a zoo somewhere down in country but
far away and so
Barry had to find the animal and then
had to identify the route and then there
were bridges that were obviously not
strong enough to hold a truck with an
elephant so he put together a plan to
retrofit let's say the Four Bridges
however many there were between here and
there and he put together this whole
plan which is very berry and literally
was about to execute the plan when
Coppola said oh it's done we're done
like you don't have to do the plan wow
yeah and that's movie making planning
for all kinds of things being told Oh
Billy Dom we need you you're gonna do a
thing and you got to get ready we're
gonna do it in a week and you're like
totally right oh no we can't do the
thing yeah yeah we're gonna fly down to
twizel for a week and a half two weeks
just to be on wet weather cover and we
might need you every single day and they
ended up not needing news at all and we
went man didn't we we're dead gush
lately imagine twice yeah and there is
video footage yeah I've lost yeah you've
got to find that
um well that's brilliant okay so let's
let's try and get back on top sorry yeah
so you're at new line you have you
you've become a champion for Peter
Jackson's work he then presents to you
this idea that he needs to get this Lord
of the Rings double set of movies yeah
over the Finish Line is it is it Bob
share Michael Lim that's yeah into three
yeah but Bob Shay was in the room along
with Peter Fran Ken Commons they're then
agent now manager long time partner
um you're there and I'm there and yeah
and that's and Bob say who I remain
close with to this day who's famously
inscrutable
hard to read
um and uh you know he watched the whole
presentation Peter done a video that
showed how forced perspective would make
you know normal size actors you know you
how massive was going to work how Gollum
was going to work and you just couldn't
tell how it was going how the whole
pitch was going
um and then Bob sort of very famously
said well tolkien's already done his
your job for you why two films
why not three and that was like it's
literally I imagine the moment must have
been like trying to get a wild animal to
eat out of your hand without scaring it
away right right because I'm sure Peter
and Fran must have been thinking
yes I mean three people in Fran are
relatively inscrutable as well yeah what
would do you recall their reaction do
you think that they wanted three but
they weren't able to negotiate it I
think all of them were sort of like
yes totally we could do that and then we
set about a process where by the two
film plan and the budget and the script
had to then be reconstituted and then
suddenly Philippa and Peter friend had
to turn it into three scripts and a
whole new production plan and a whole
new budget which obviously went up and
as it should and yeah then we were
underway and then casting do you
remember what year that would be yeah
that was they came in in July of
I want to say of 98 we shot started
shooting in October of 99. so it would
have been in July August of of 98 when
that meeting happened as it basically at
that meeting just to let people know how
it go do they basically get a yes there
is it it's an incremental yes so they
got it we got a yes which meant we that
which meant new line now had to make
deals with Miramax salzance and Peter
and fratton too right to to make deals
to do this once those deals were made
then a sort of enhanced r d development
process started whereby we kept spending
money to support the sort of r d process
the writing process the budgeting
process all the different things and
then it got to a green light where
instead of looking at spending maybe 20
million dollars to like you know to see
if we could do it yep now we're going to
see if we gonna spend 200 million
dollars to actually make it so the green
light is when that's set yeah these
films are getting made at this price and
at that point are you
you know you're part of the movie at
that point I did when my honest thought
up until Lord of the Rings the most
expensive film at work new line I worked
on was six million dollars yeah so I
actually had zero expectation of working
on the films I thought my job was simply
to be an advocate for Peter to bring him
in to hopefully lay some foundation with
hitting in Bob and then if it worked yay
and they'd get someone else on the team
to work on it who was more experienced
than me because the budget for for the
original trilogy was what 262-70 it was
Greenland at like 207 207 and then some
X and then then as time went by more and
the brilliant thing about new line is
the sort of the pride of authorship and
I remember Shea said like who else are
we gonna have to it you read the books
when you were a kid he's your friend
right sleeps on your couch right
who else is going to know if it's
working or not working you're going yeah
you're perfectly positioned and then the
irony is
so they would send me down
and I would go to sort of look out for
things like to be look out for the
Studio's interest and then Peter would
then pull me into so many things that I
didn't even realize I'd get pulled into
because in his mind it was in his
benefit that I was knowledgeable about
anything that was going on yeah So
eventually I could speak to the studio
about things that he didn't have to
speak about so everything so the more I
went the more I wasn't allowed to leave
and I just stayed you're the go between
so just to just to back up a little bit
when so so
you guys are all in that office
Bob shame and Michael Lynn said why
don't we turn it into a Trilogy instead
of two Pete and Fran and Phil say that
sounds great is there a is there a point
through that process where those guys
Phil and Fran and P have a little moment
with you of like we did it or do you
never fully get there because there's
new targets to say I don't remember that
moment
um the really the oh the real I think I
think the moment I really felt that is
when the films were actually greenlit
right when they're really green and by
the time they were green lit you all
were in it right even though we hadn't
met like I knew you were there like I
the casting process had gone on all the
major rules were cast and the whole
thing it was sort of that because that
that point you you know how it is when
you make films and television you don't
really know you're making it until
you're yeah they're making it walking on
set so so so the film gets green lit do
you recall how quickly you then went to
New Zealand and were kind of piece right
hand man I can't remember how quickly I
just know that I went increasingly more
and more where my whole calendar started
shifting where I measured it by not so
much how much time I was going to go
down for but how much time I was coming
back so it just sort of happened over
time there was always things to do right
Pete obviously had Wingnuts
was was up and running for a while
before that and wet uh but it's a it's a
completely different wetter than what it
is now do you recall the first time
walking around that wetter and what it
was like yeah it was it was great it was
because basically weather the DNA of
weather is was the same then as it is
now it was like Innovative and envelope
pushing and what Lord of the Rings
enabled to have happen is just
unbelievable amounts of resources
getting pumped into the place so that
all these talented people could just do
a lot more right right that's really
what happened the spirit of the place is
really no different right I saw arpeggio
today actually from where to where I
think it was very early on well they got
maybe 40 people and and and did them all
as Orcs I don't know if you saw that
right yeah and it's got when would that
have been with that that definitely
would have been during pre-production
because all those orc masks because they
don't even look like the actual finish
not quite yeah but it's starting to get
the stale isn't it it must have been so
weird been down there when those
decisions are being made because I'm
sure you've seen things
that never made it to the movie that
maybe even you wanted or didn't want or
yeah all the changes that we will never
know was there you sort of have to Hold
On Loosely I find because if you because
you basically want to back
it's all about backing the artists if
you're someone you know Michael DeLuca
who runs um who runs MGM but who is that
new line at the time and whom uh gave me
this great advice sort of like 90 of the
job is picking the right people or being
picked by them right okay because if you
don't get that right then everything
else you do is struggle you know so if
you've picked the right people or you've
been picked then you're about enhancing
enabling facilitating that process if
you picked wrong or you've been picked
wrongly then no matter how hard you try
everything's going to be struggling
right because with P ultimately you know
being the the Puppet Master on those
Trilogy of films based on his ability
and his level of talent it all trickles
down from yeah for sure just to touch
about what what you just said there I
remember us all being so excited that we
were going to film this sequence in the
boats where we got attacked on the
shoreline by Orcs oh yeah yeah and about
three or four days before we were going
to start doing that sequence which I
think was going to be at least a week if
not more of filming Queenstown was
flooded and the sets got completely
washed away and Pete just said well we
just won't do it and what's that like as
a producer yeah I mean that must be nice
I mean flooded Queenstown you can't even
think about it because you it's
basically you have to be sort of
addicted to problem solving yeah
otherwise it's complete matters and you
have to sort of look at it as
opportunity
otherwise you'll just go crazy I
remember when we arrived in Queenstown
and they had uh ladders up in the hotel
you couldn't get in because there was no
four years yeah it was underwater and we
went up ladders into the first floor and
we're like this can be where we're
filming it was crazy people working down
the main street in canoes we weren't we
were advised not to go into the center
of town because there was a few
restaurants we wanted to go to and yeah
go have some fun and we were advised
because the water had now become a
little fettered and not gray we spent
one of our afternoons I remember you and
I helping people move sandbags around
you know there was there was tons
literally tons of sandbags at this hotel
and we were moving them from one part
that wasn't as flooded as the other part
to the overly flooded section so for us
a sort of Adventure but I'm sure for you
Mark is like sleepless nights on the
phone to Bob schacing we've just lost
half a million dollars
it's funny
I learned a lot of valuable lessons on
rings one of the things when when a
problem happens
find the solution and then communicate
the problem right which is something
that it when your earnest like me that's
not the Natural Instinct the natural
instances I'll communicate everything in
real time but if you're calling about
the problem and you don't have a
solution are you really doing any good
right are you doing anybody any good
including yourself right by doing that I
mean I remember Council of elrond
there's a Queenstown thing too
um it was shooting obviously we were in
Queenstown a bunch of times for
different things but one time I was
there I was looking forward to seeing
things I was hardly ever on set it was
kind of hysterical but
and Peter said well the Council of
elrond is like if we shoot the counts of
elrond is this currently scripted it's
going to be like a 45 minute not
literally but it's going to be some
gigantic thing and that's obviously not
viable but the scene has to be the scene
and Philip and Fran are are working on
it so you should go and work you know be
there sounding board as be helpful go be
helpful
so I said great I'll go be helpful and
then you realize this thing is shooting
like next week and you realize the
pressure and the consequences if you
think for a minute like gosh if we don't
if this doesn't get sorted then next
week is gonna
suffer the consequences of something not
Fran's whole thing about laying track
before the moving train that's where
that stuff comes from right right and
then you realize oh this actually has to
be solved we can actually can't spend
any time telling people that there's a
problem it just has to be solved right
right yeah and we were saying just
before you came on that that you have
this innate ability Mark whether it's
just your personality or or how good you
are at your job that you're able to wear
a lot of hats and do that really well I
always felt in my naivety back in New
Zealand when I was 24 I kind of thought
okay so
odeski is kind of the go-between for the
actors and the studio but that wasn't
your job at all that was one of them
though you were really good at that with
us that I thought oh that's what Mark's
doing but obviously you were doing
specific jobs for new line and Bob Shea
and Mike Lem you were doing specific
jobs for Pete and Fran and Philippa but
every time I saw you I was like oh
Mark's like this this kind of oil in
between everyone where he's making sure
everyone's okay and everyone's having a
good time and are there any problems you
need to talk to us about and um you know
we're all much younger men back then we
were out and about partying and you know
eating meals and drinking and having fun
and I remember just thinking it's like
Mark's been here the in the entire time
yeah you know
and I think I I even read that I'm sure
maybe this isn't true but uh you you
went to Pete once with something and
Pete got you doing off off camera games
yes Pete has a great sense of humor
because I've since I've known him since
the mid-80s he could read me I'm not
that hard to read but he could
definitely read me and I was
I was coming to suffer so if I'm coming
to set and it's not about set there's a
problem then that means I'm about to
interrupt right and I must obviously
feel it's very timely so I came marching
my my markway purposefully and he saw me
coming and before I could open my mouth
he said
so good you're here we're doing like Van
Horn forest and no one's here to do
gimli's offlines really and we've got
we've got Ian here we've got you know
Orlando we've got Vigo if you stand
behind that tree you can do gimli's
lines it'll be so helpful Ian won't it
be helpful oh yes oh yes
be very very helpful so for three hours
I was stuck behind the tree and by the
way there's almost no photographs of me
on set Lord there's one photograph which
I am convinced of this day Peter had
someone take I'm sitting there looking
borderline Moody Broody
um holding my little sides which I never
held sides because why would I have them
right
um reading off lines and looking I got
played nice I love that yeah Pizza she
also tricked me into announcing the
world premiere of Return of the King in
museum during Two Towers he did the same
to me in a much more minor way he pulled
the same trick that he pulled on you so
with you you at the Wellington wait no
where was The Two Towers Wellington
Premiere which was not the world
premiere of Two Towers was not in LA or
New York for Two Towers I think no for
two times I think it was in the
London was it I think it was in London
yeah so at the premiere for two towers
in Wellington he brought you up well you
were on stage but you brought you up in
front of the mic and said where is the
world premiere for The Return of the
King gonna be and you were like
Wellington you did the same thing to me
ish at the One Ring party at the Oscars
when it was the clean sweep the um
for the Return of the King at the Oscars
he mentioned that prank that I pulled on
Elijah where I played the German
journalist and he said while I was on
stage with him you know Don did this
really funny prank and we'd love to have
it on the DVD extras what do you guys
all think and look around yay and then
he said what do you think Dom and I went
yeah sounds great I want to throw me
some cash no okay we'll do it for free
Dom hey fantastic chat with Mark yes I'm
having a good time with this one yeah
he's a fascinating Guy and because we
spoke at length we're going to split it
into two aren't we I think it's a good
idea though because uh great stories and
I think really interesting to hear
the the stories a lot arranged from a
producer's point of view
um and and hear how that was different
and you know we hear a lot from the
actors and I think it's really
interesting to hear from Mark I agree
and I think a lot of people out there
that might not be involved in our
business think okay the director is the
ultimate boss and the director makes all
these decisions but without a producer
helping the director to be able to make
those artistic choices you you're really
in in a mess you know producers make
sure that their director can have their
best day on set and Mark being involved
in what must have been one of the more
complicated trilogies to ever make if
not the most complicated Trilogy because
that that I mean that would be quite
overwhelming for me to you can do it I
honestly don't I'll tell you right now
yeah I don't actually so if you want to
be a producer if you want to know what
life as a producer is like and some of
the pressures and responsibilities
um
tune in next week as well because Mark's
exactly he's gonna break it break it
break it break it break it down so
you'll be hearing it from one of the
great producers and uh hearing it from
market and one of the two truly average
actors myself and Billy
don't forget to write in to
um the Friendship onion at castmedia.com
or leave a message yes speakpape.com
forward slash the Friendship onion re
review subscribe subscribing is very
important especially if you want to hear
the story of me um share yourself at
work into a pair of um open-toed sandals
did they have a heel did they have in
the field no okay it was kind of a
velcro grip
threw him away quite soon after the
incidents anymore don't tell us anymore
once we got 200 000 uh subscribers I
will uh unleash that story in the same
way that my bowels did upon the tops of
my thighs
um which is a shame when I think about
it but the reason why I tell this story
is I actually heard initially for the
first kind of half an hour quite a lot
of Shame
associated with that story yeah when I
ran to the bathroom dripping
haters my legs yeah to just clean my
dirty thighs I remember thinking this is
the most embarrassing thing that's ever
happened to caters in public yeah yeah
it would be and I thought the thing to
do now wait a minute are you telling us
bit the thing to do now is tell everyone
tell everyone right so that's why in
this particular platform when we get 200
000 uh followers I like to tell everyone
because then there's no shame shame
likes to be hidden no don't hide it no
bring it out into the open bring it into
the light and once we get 300 000 Dom
and I will write a song called when
Dom's hate herself in public
um so subscribe to the Friendship onion
leave your comments questions concerns
on our YouTube channel we love trying to
do tongue twisters we love hearing about
song lyrics that you inadvertently or
purposefully get wrong and there was
another thing oh riddles I love a good
riddle riddle me this storm that sounds
as if I had a riddle there but I don't
didn't have one no there's a great
riddle in the new the Batman film I mean
try it for you is it the Riddler who
does it is it I've not seen the film oh
well there you go should I try if you
want yeah
um
what does a liar do when he's dead
lies
almost lies down lies still lie still
amazing absolutely nailed it see you
next week see ya on the Friendship
bunion
[Music]
baby you're my Pearl
[Music]